i just want to make a quick announcement  to the youtube subscribers out there  that we've been adding a lot on the  history section of khan academy and it  hasn't just been videos on the videos  we've added a lot on earlier early 20th  century history on  before world war one entering into world  war one the period between world war one  and world war ii including nazi germany  and fascist italy and on top of that  it's not just videos it's also exercises  so for example at the end of a tutorial  you could click on the exercise and you  could actually get quizzed on that idea  and it's not just there we have our art  historians have also been doing a lot on  renaissance and reformation so i  encourage you all to go to  the site and check this stuff out it's  pretty fun general interest stuff even  if you're not in a history class we  think you will learn things that you  might have not known before and you get  to quiz yourself on it as well